In this video I’ll be analysing how horror
2018 stacks up with other years for the genre.
If you want to hear what might be in store
for 2019, then stick around to the end of
this video.
An article has been making the rounds in the
horror community titled, ‘Wasn’t This
Supposed To Be The Golden Age Of Horror?’
The author’s thesis is that the horror genre
has really deflated since last year and there
hasn’t been a good scary movie in 2018.
Now last time I talked about an article on
DeadTalks, I basically destroyed the guy,
to the point that he completely went silent
on the matter and deleted all his tweets linking
to the article.
My goal this time is not to destroy anyone,
but to simply to look back and see how this
year stacks up to previous years in terms
of what audiences thought, what critics thought,
and what I thought.
At least, that was my initial goal, to offer
an objective comparison of each year.
My hypothesis was that 2018 isn’t really
a bad year overall, but compared to the amazing
years we had in 2016 and even to some extent
last year in 2017, 2018 just doesn’t have
the firepower to compete.
However, as I started to crunch the numbers,
I realized more and more issues with this
comparison.
So my new point of this video, is that you
can’t really objectively compare year to
year.
I can give my own feelings on which years
were best, but even those are going to be
skewed and here’s why.
The first year I started logging every film
I watched was 2014, so let’s start there.
This is where I realized the first issue with
this experiment -- how do you define a horror
film?
If you include dark thrillers like Gone Girl
or Nightcrawler, then I’d consider 2014
to be a pretty decent year.
If you take those out, you’ve got It Follows
and The Guest, both of which I love, but then
after that, there aren’t a lot of heavy
hitters.
Even if you only go by horror movies by the
strictest definition of the word, there are
basically countless amounts of movies that
come out every year.
Do you include all MPAA major releases?
But then what about indie films?
Do you try to include good, bad and mid-tier
films from each year and take the average
audience, critic and personal scores of each
movie?
What happens if you have a bunch of good films,
but also a bunch of bad ones?
Is that considered a good year or a bad year?
What if you have the best film of the decade
one year, but it’s weighed down some stinkers
that also came out that year?
How do you even decide what year a movie came
out?
Many films premiere at a festival, then have
their wide release a different year, so the
year that the majority of people watch the
movie is not the year the movie came out?
Let’s not even start to bring up the fact
that the article claims 2018 was a bad year
for horror, yet it only talks about movies
with the addition of a couple TV shows and
high budget web-series.
For simplicity’s sake, we can’t even get
into games or books… and I know you’re
not going to diss on horror YouTubers, otherwise
we’re gonna have a PROBLEM!!!
But yeah, I really don’t see a fair way
to compare these years.
You could frame any of them to be the worst
year of the bunch, maybe with the exception
of 2016.
I don’t see how anyone could come to the
conclusion that that year sucked, but then
again, I’m just basing that off of my opinion
of the movies that I saw.
I try to see movies that I think I’m gonna
like, but I imagine a different person with
different tastes, could see a different set
of movies and have different opinions of each
movie.
See... this is why I analyse films in Things
You Missed and I’m not a ranker, or reviewer.
But with that all being said, let’s get
to what you’re all here, for: my opinion.
So we start with 2014.
I’ll be going by the movie release dates
listed on a film database called TMDB.
It uses the original premiere dates of the
film as it’s release date.
So although I didn’t actually get to see
It Follows until 2015, when it was released
commercially in theaters, it will technically
be considered a 2014 film for the purposes
of this argument.
I can already tell you It Follows was my favorite
film of the decade, and really, my favorite
film in a long time.
The other highlights are, as I mentioned,
probably closer to the thriller side of the
venn diagram: Gone Girl and Nightcrawler,
before horror films like The Guest and [REC]
4.
And let’s get this out of the way now -- The
Babadook.
I know people love that movie and that’s
fine, I found it to be kind of an average
cliche supernatural movie that came out basically
at the end of the supernatural trend that
Paranormal Activity started in 2007.
The following year was 2015, and that’s
also pretty solid, headlined by Joel Edgerton’s
surprise hit The Gift.
This is where we also have to address the
question of what we do with horror-comedy,
and since The Visit is equal parts horror
and comedy, I’m willing to put that on the
list.
Insidious: Chapter 3 was almost a skip for
me, but I am so glad I ended up seeing it,
because it might just be as good as the first
Insidious.
I’d say 2015 has a few drawbacks though.
Unfriended was at least funny in an unintentional
way...
"Ken?
Ken?"
"What is he doing?"
"Ken!!"
"Oh man, that's hilarious"
"Is he OK?"
"Ken?"
"HAHA!
Oh my God!
WAHAHA!
He put his hand in the blender!
WAHAHAHAHA!
You gotta be kidding me!
That's how he kills himself?"
...but you may have forgotten about The
Poltergeist remake and the even more maligned
Paranormal Activity: The Ghost Dimension.
I liked both of these years, but even the
strength of their highlights isn’t going
to stack up to what would follow.
Of my top in 2016, 6 of them are in the territory
of horror or dark thriller.
If you saw my last video you already know
how I feel about Split, but add on 10 Cloverfield
Lane, Don’t Breathe, Light’s Out, the
arguably more thriller oriented Nerve, but
also the more traditional horror piece, The
Boy and you’ve got a stellar list of highlights.
But even 2016 isn’t without a few disappointments,
and they came from respectable directors,
like Adam Wingard's’ Blair Witch, Rob Zombie’s
31 and Gore Verbinski’s return to horror
with A Cure for Wellness.
The author of the article seemed to have a
lot of praise for 2017, so let’s look at
what we got that year.
It Comes At Night was the leader of the pack
for me, I’ll never understand why people
thought the trailer was misleading or something
-- or how that would make the movie itself
lose credibility, but that might be a topic
for a different DeadTalk.
I will say that It Comes At Night doesn’t
have the punch that It Follows had in ‘14,
The Gift had in ‘15 or Split had in ‘16,
but you can’t really blame Shultsy for that,
it’s still very well done.
‘17 might be the year of divisiveness actually,
because I’ve got mother! near the top of
my list as well.
And who could forget IT?
I know I included The Visit, but I’m not
going to include Get Out, since that one is
much closer to comedy than it is horror.
This next one I’m only going to point out
because I know people will pull out some less
than desirable films when we get to the 2018
discussion.
Let’s not forget that one of the worst atrocities
of the decade took place in 2017.
"Please don't say it."
At least Paranormal Activity: The Ghost Dimension
was the 6th movie of a franchise that had
already lost it’s touch several movies ago.
The Bye Bye Man really has no excuses for
itself.
In fact, I saw this movie before it officially
came out.
This was before it had achieved meme status,
and all I could come up to say about this
film was, “a movie so bad, I can pretty
much guarantee it will become a meme.”
I literally predicted the future when I wrote
that.
Let’s look at some of the popular reviews.
The peepee poopoo man.
457 likes.
I’ve been chanting ‘the bye bye man, the
bye bye man’ for the past 2 hours to see
if i can get him to kill me so i can forget
about this movie.
I’m sorry I really don’t like focusing
on the negative, but there’s just a special
place in hell for this one.
So that just leaves us with 2018.
I feel like most of us will agree that Hereditary
and A Quiet Place should occupy the top two
spots so far this year in some order.
Insidious: The Last Key wasn’t terrible
for a January film, and for a fourth film
in a franchise on it’s third director…
it was acceptable.
The rest of the year… it had people literally
eating Tide Pods.
We had The Cloverfield Paradox -- not the
worst thing I’ve ever seen, and kind of
goes more sci-fi than horror, but when you
put it next to the first two movies, it just
pales.
And who could forget this historic Things
You Missed intro?
Roll it.
(Clip)
There were a lot of tentpole movies this year…
but did any of them really blow you away?
In this case, I have to agree with the author
of the article, 2018 is a step down overall
from previous years.
But, before we wrap this up, let’s revisit
my hypothesis, that 2018 is weaker than recent
years, but that’s partially because recent
years have been pretty strong.
I started this comparison at 2014 because
that's when I started logging my movies.
However, a few Google searches for horror
movies from 2010-2013 brought me back to the
dark ages.
An era where you were lucky to get an awesome
horror movie once a year, let alone two, or
six.
The tide started to turn -- no not that Tide.
The tide started to turn late in 2014, when
people started to chatter about an incredibly
clever monster film with creepy synth soundtrack.
From that point, we would get a new gem every
year, sometimes several.
Twenty-seventeen didn’t have a 5-star mind-blowing
movie leading the way like the previous years,
but it did feature a massive $700M grossing
picture that floated all the way to the top
of the world of horror, but maybe more impressively
was a hit with fans as well.
So in my opinion, 2018 is a bit of a dip from
recent years, but I’d still consider it
be part of a pretty awesome stretch of years
in latter half of this decade.
And we’ve got one more.
In less than 2 months, assuming these wildfires
don’t do to me what Carrie White did to
her prom classmates, I’ll make it to the
long awaited California 2019.
And it’s sure to be a year for all you crash
queens and motor babies.
Listen up!
The future is bulletproof!
The Bye Bye Man is secondary.
It’s time to do it now and do it loud.
Horror bois.
Make some noise!
It Chapter 2!
Happy Death Day 2U!
Some mutants that are new.
World War Z.
Number 2.
Got a new.
Alien.
Got a werewolf in London.
Give me more give me more give me more!
You don’t want.
To be buried.
In a Pet Sematary.
Got some J-horror with Grudge!
No one knows what’s up with Us.
Child’s Play’s.
Coming back.
Start the year off right with Glass!
Give me more, give me more, give me more -- shut
up and sing it with me.
Na na na na na na.
There’s a new Zombieland.
Rob Zombie’s coming back.
Na na na na na na.
And we’ll be Conjuring!
Are you a.
Fraid of the dark?
I hope not.
Or you will not.
Have a good year.
When 2019 is here….
See you in the next one.